selamat datang kembali di Understanding Quantum Information and Computation, nama saya John Matus dan saya adalah direktur teknis bidang pendidikan di IBM
Quantum ini adalah pelajaran ke-12 dalam seri ini dan merupakan pelajaran terakhir di unit ketiga yang membahas tentang
formulasi umum informasi kuantum pelajaran ini berpusat pada konsep fundamental dalam informasi kuantum yaitu
purifikasi dari Keadaan Kuantum sebuah purifikasi dari Keadaan Kuantum yang diwakili oleh suatu matriks densitas adalah
keadaan murni dari sistem gabungan yang lebih besar yang meninggalkan kita dengan keadaan asal saat sisa sistem gabungan tersebut
dibuang atau di-trace out setiap matriks densitas punya purifikasi dan kita bisa belajar banyak
tentang Keadaan Kuantum dan informasi kuantum secara umum dengan mempelajari purifikasi pada level intuitif
vektor keadaan kuantum yang mewakili keadaan murni adalah objek matematis yang lebih sederhana dibanding matriks densitas dan dengan memikirkan
purifikasi dari keadaan kita bisa melihat keadaan kuantum sembarang dari sistem sebagai bagian dari sesuatu yang lebih besar tapi
lebih sederhana kita juga akan membahas Fidelitas antara dua keadaan kuantum yang merupakan nilai yang mengukur
kemiripan atau tumpang tindih keduanya dan sering digunakan sebagai cara mengukur seberapa baik suatu keadaan tertentu dibandingkan dengan
keadaan ideal khususnya kita akan membahas definisi fidelitas beserta beberapa sifat dasarnya dan kita akan melihat
bagaimana Fidelitas berhubungan dengan purifikasi berikut adalah gambaran umum pelajaran ini kita akan mulai dengan purifikasi termasuk
definisi dan bukti sederhana tentang keberadaannya yang memberi tahu kita cara menemukannya jika diperlukan lalu kita akan membahas sesuatu yang dikenal
sebagai dekomposisi Schmid dari sebuah Vektor Keadaan Kuantum dari dua sistem dan kita akan melihat bagaimana dekomposisi Schmid berhubungan dengan
purifikasi kemudian kita akan membahas hubungan yang sangat penting antara dua purifikasi mana pun dari keadaan yang sama yang dikenal sebagai
ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi dan akhirnya kita akan membahas beberapa contoh lalu kita beralih ke Fidelitas
termasuk definisi dan beberapa sifat dasarnya kita akan membahas Lemma pengukuran gentle yang merupakan fakta yang sangat
berguna yang menghubungkan Fidelitas kembali ke pengukuran dan akhirnya untuk mengakhiri pelajaran kita akan beralih ke teorema Uhlmann yang
menetapkan hubungan fundamental antara Fidelitas dan purifikasi mari kita mulai dengan
definisi purifikasi sebuah purifikasi dari suatu keadaan yang diasumsikan diwakili oleh sebuah matriks
densitas adalah keadaan murni dari sistem gabungan yang lebih besar yang meninggalkan keadaan asal yang kita mulai ketika sisanya
dari sistem gabungan di-trace out kita bisa mengungkapkan ini lebih tepat dalam istilah matematis sebagai
berikut jika kita punya sistem X yang berada dalam suatu keadaan row yang berarti row adalah matriks densitas yang mewakili keadaan X
dan S adalah Vektor Keadaan Kuantum dari sepasang sistem XY sedemikian sehingga me-trace out y dari keadaan murni C sisi bro plus I
meninggalkan kita dengan row maka kita katakan bahwa s adalah purifikasi dari row tentu saja nama-namanya tidak penting
kita bisa menamakan sistem dan keadaan kita sesuka hati dan urutan sistemnya juga tidak penting misalnya
jika sistem y ada di sisi kiri daripada sisi kanan tapi semuanya sama kita tetap akan menyebut SAI sebagai purifikasi dari row tapi kita akan
tetap berpegang pada pengaturan ini untuk sisa pelajaran hanya demi kesederhanaan dan hal pertama yang perlu dikatakan
tentang definisi adalah bahwa purifikasi selalu ada untuk setiap matriks densitas row dan lebih tepatnya setiap matriks
densitas row punya purifikasi seperti yang dijelaskan definisi asalkan sistem y setidaknya sebesar X yang
artinya y memiliki setidaknya sebanyak keadaan klasik seperti X konsep purifikasi dan
fakta bahwa purifikasi selalu ada ternyata sangat penting dan ini juga bagian dari yang membuat informasi kuantum indah dan semoga saya bisa
meyakinkan kalian tentang fakta itu pada akhir pelajaran sekarang mari kita buktikan bahwa setiap matriks densitas punya purifikasi dan dalam
prosesnya kita akan melihat bagaimana kita bisa mendapatkan purifikasi saat kita membutuhkannya seperti yang kita miliki dalam definisi
sebuah purifikasi misalkan X adalah sistem dan row adalah matriks densitas yang mewakili keadaan
X sekarang pertimbangkan ekspresi row mana pun sebagai kombinasi cembung dari keadaan murni seperti yang tertulis di layar dalam kata-kata
untuk beberapa pilihan bilangan bulat positif n kita punya vektor probabilitas p 0 sampai pN minus1 serta vektor
keadaan kuantum 5 0 sampai 5 nus satu dan dengan merata-ratakan keadaan murni yang sesuai berbobot oleh probabilitas kita
mendapatkan Row misalnya kita bisa menggunakan teorema spektral untuk mendapatkan ekspresi row seperti ini dan jika kita melakukan itu
kita bisa mengambil n sebagai jumlah keadaan klasik dari X bahkan kita bisa mengambil n sebagai rank dari row yang
sama dengan jumlah nilai eigen tak nol dari row menghitung masing-masing satu kali sejumlah kali sesuai multiplicitynya dan
itu tidak pernah lebih besar dari jumlah keadaan klasik X tapi bisa lebih kecil di sisi lain ini tidak
harus menjadi dekomposisi spektral dari row dan kita tidak memerlukan vektor-vektor Keadaan Kuantum ini untuk bersifat ortogonal misalnya ekspresi row mana pun seperti ini
tidak masalah dan inilah purifikasi dari row jumlahnya mencakup nilai yang sama seperti
dalam ekspresi row kita dan di dalam jumlah tersebut kita mengambil akar kuadrat dari probabilitas yang dikalikan dengan F A yang di-tensor
dengan k a di sini omong-omong kita mengasumsikan bahwa 0 sampai n minus satu adalah keadaan klasik dari sistem kedua y jadi
masuk akal bahwa s adalah Vektor Keadaan Kuantum dari pasangan XY seperti dalam definisi sebenarnya tidak penting
di sini bahwa kita menggunakan keadaan basis standar dari Y dalam ekspresi ini kamu bisa mengganti koleksi ortonormal mana pun dari
keadaan sebagai pengganti K 0 sampai Kat n minus satu jika kamu mau dan sekarang kita bisa memeriksa bahwa ini memang
sebuah purifikasi dengan menghitung Partial Trace terhadap y berikut adalah ekspresi dari keadaan yang kita dapatkan dengan melakukan partial trace
trace dari k a bra B adalah satu atau nol tergantung apakah a sama dengan B atau tidak dan jadi ekspresinya
disederhanakan ke ekspresi asal kita dari row dan sesederhana itu jadi sangat mudah untuk mendapatkan
purifikasi selama kita punya cukup keadaan klasik dari Y atau alternatifnya himpunan ortonormal yang cukup besar untuk digunakan sebagai
pengganti keadaan basis standar kat 0 sampai kat n minus satu dan omong-omong jika jumlah
keadaan klasik Y lebih kecil dari rank row maka tidak akan ada purifikasi dan saya biarkan itu untuk
kamu renungkan jika kamu mau berikut adalah contohnya mari kita pertimbangkan
matriks densitas yang kita lihat beberapa kali dalam pelajaran tentang matriks densitas di sini kita punya ekspresi dari
matriks densitas ini sebagai kombinasi cembung dari keadaan murni ini bukan dekomposisi spektral tapi kita tidak
peduli dan dengan hampir tanpa usaha sama sekali kita bisa menuliskan purifikasi dari keadaan tersebut dengan mengikuti
resepnya itu bukan satu-satunya purifikasi dari matriks densitas ini purifikasi tidak unik tapi tidak apa-apa
definisi tidak mengatakan apa pun tentang keunikan dan sebenarnya ada hubungan yang sangat menarik di antara berbagai purifikasi dari keadaan yang sama tapi
kita akan membahas itu nanti dalam pelajaran selanjutnya kita akan mempertimbangkan dekomposisi Schmid yang merupakan ekspresi dari
vektor keadaan kuantum bipartit dalam bentuk tertentu yang akan saya jelaskan sebentar lagi namanya diambil dari Erhard
Schmidt Schmid yang sama yang dikenal dengan prosedur ortogonalisasi Graham-Schmid tapi dalam kasus dekomposisi Schmid mungkin seharusnya tidak
dinamai menurut Schmidt karena sebenarnya secara matematis setara dengan sesuatu yang disebut dekomposisi nilai singular untuk matriks yang merupakan sesuatu yang
sebenarnya ditemukan ulang beberapa kali tapi memang itu kadang terjadi tapi bagaimanapun inilah yang kita maksud
saat kita menyebut dekomposisi Schmid untuk pilihan sembarang dari Vektor Keadaan Kuantum s untuk sepasang
sistem XY selalu mungkin untuk menulis s dalam bentuk khusus bentuk tersebut adalah seperti yang
terlihat di layar di mana R adalah bilangan bulat positif tertentu p 0 sampai p r minus satu adalah bilangan real positif yang
bersama-sama membentuk vektor probabilitas x0 sampai XR minus1 adalah vektor satuan yang bersesuaian dengan sistem X dan y0
sampai y rus1 adalah vektor satuan yang bersesuaian dengan sistem y sekarang itu mungkin tidak terlihat
istimewa sampai saya memberitahu kamu bahwa kedua himpunan x0 sampai XR minus satu dan y0 sampai y Rus satu harus bersifat
ortonormal jadi kenapa itu istimewa nah jika kita memilih basis mana pun untuk salah satu dari dua basis katakanlah
vektor X yang bersesuaian dengan sistem X maka kita selalu bisa mengekspresikan s dalam bentuk ini dan itu akan memaksa kita untuk
memilih vektor Y dengan cara tertentu bahkan kita melakukan ini cukup rutin seperti yang kita lakukan dengan basis standar saat kita
menyiapkan diri untuk menganalisis pengukuran basis standar tapi secara umum meskipun kita memilih basis ortonormal untuk
vektor X vektor Y yang kita dapatkan belum tentu bersifat ortonormal demikian pula jika kamu memilih
basis ortonormal untuk vektor Y dan kamu mencoba mengekspresikan s dalam bentuk tersebut kamu bisa tapi lagi-lagi vektor X tidak akan
harus bersifat ortonormal dan akhirnya jika kamu memilih vektor ortonormal untuk kedua sistem dan
kamu mencoba mengekspresikan s dalam bentuk seperti ini itu belum tentu berhasil karena kamu mungkin membutuhkan beberapa suku silang tapi hanya ada satu
indeks dalam jumlah ini yaitu a sehingga bentuknya istimewa tapi memang selalu mungkin untuk
menulis vektor satuan s yang diberikan seperti ini dan inilah cara kamu melakukannya pertama hitung dekomposisi spektral
untuk keadaan tereduksi dari salah satu dari dua sistem tidak masalah yang mana tapi demi menjelaskan cara melakukannya mari kita lihat keadaan tereduksi dari
X jadi kita me-trace out y yang berarti p 0 sampai p r minus satu adalah nilai
eigen dari keadaan tereduksi row ini dan x0 sampai XR minus satu adalah vektor eigen satuan yang bersesuaian dengan nilai eigen ini dan
omong-omong pemahamannya di sini adalah kita mengabaikan suku-suku yang nilai eigennya nol karena suku-suku tersebut tidak berkontribusi apa pun pada
jumlah dan artinya p 0 sampai p r minus satu semuanya bilangan real positif dan R adalah jumlah nilai eigen
tak nol menghitung multiplicitasnya yang sama dengan rank dari row jadi itu memberi kita p 0 sampai p r
minus satu serta x0 sampai XR minus satu dan yang tersisa hanyalah menemukan vektor y0 sampai y Rus
satu hanya ada satu pilihan yang bisa berhasil vektor-vektor tersebut ditentukan secara unik pada titik ini dan bisa
dengan mudah ditemukan menggunakan rumus sederhana yang ditampilkan di layar dan yang mengagumkan di sini adalah bahwa
jika kita mendefinisikan vektor-vektor ini dengan cara ini maka dijamin bersifat ortonormal dan itu memberi kita dekomposisi Schmid saya tidak akan membuktikannya dalam
video ini tapi tidak terlalu sulit dan kamu bisa merujuk ke materi tertulis untuk pelajaran ini jika tertarik cek
deskripsi video untuk linknya seperti biasa sebagai contoh mari kita pertimbangkan
Vektor Keadaan Kuantum yang kita dapatkan sebagai purifikasi dari contoh matriks densitas yang terus kita kembalikan
ini bukan dekomposisi Schmid karena keadaan nol dan plus tidak ortonormal tapi kita bisa menemukannya
menggunakan prosedur yang baru saya jelaskan langkah pertama adalah menghitung dekomposisi spektral untuk keadaan tereduksi
dari X yang merupakan contoh matriks densitas yang sama dan berikut adalah dekomposisi spektralnya yang kita lihat sebelumnya
di pelajaran 9 jadi kita pilih p 0 P1 x0 dan X1 seperti yang
ditampilkan di layar p 0 dan P1 adalah nilai eigen dari row dan x0 dan X1 adalah
vektor eigen satuan yang bersesuaian dan jadi yang tersisa adalah menghitung y0 dan y1 dan jika kita melakukannya kita mendapatkan kat Plus
untuk y0 dan -1 kali Kat minus untuk y1 itu tidak langsung terlihat kamu harus
benar-benar melakukan perhitungannya untuk melihatnya tapi itulah yang kita dapatkan dan seperti yang diharapkan kedua vektor tersebut ortonormal sebagaimana
mestinya jika kamu telah melakukan perhitungan dengan benar dan itu memberi kita dekomposisi
Schmid dekomposisi Schmid sangat berguna dalam banyak situasi dan sebentar lagi kita akan melihat apa yang mereka katakan kepada kita
tentang purifikasi purifikasi tidak unik suatu Keadaan Kuantum yang diwakili
oleh matriks densitas sebenarnya akan memiliki tak terhingga banyak purifikasi namun ada hubungan erat
yang selalu berlaku antara dua purifikasi mana pun dari keadaan yang sama dan kadang disebut sebagai
ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi inilah cara kerjanya misalkan row adalah matriks densitas
yang mewakili keadaan kuantum dari sistem X dan misalkan kita punya dua purifikasi mana pun dari keadaan tersebut yang merupakan
keadaan murni dari sistem gabungan yang sama jadi demi kekonkretan misalkan s dan fi
adalah vektor keadaan kuantum dari sepasang sistem XY yang keduanya menghasilkan row saat sistem Y di-trace out
apa yang dikatakan ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi adalah bahwa harus ada operasi uniter U yang hanya bekerja pada
sistem y yang mengubah SII menjadi fi dengan kata lain meskipun ini adalah
purifikasi row yang sembarang dan kita tidak mengasumsikan apa pun tentang keduanya kecuali bahwa keduanya memurnikan row dan keduanya merupakan
keadaan dari sistem gabungan XY yang sama keduanya harus ekuivalen dalam artian tertentu hingga operasi uniter pada y
saja kita akan melihat beberapa contoh yang mengilustrasikan mengapa ini menarik dan implikasi apa yang dimilikinya tapi pertama mari kita
lihat mengapa itu benar mari kita mulai dengan dekomposisi spektral dari row yang merupakan
matriks densitas yang dimurnikan oleh SII dan fi dan sama seperti yang kita lakukan saat membahas dekomposisi Schmid kita akan
mengasumsikan bahwa kita telah membuang semua suku yang bersesuaian dengan nilai eigen nol jadi p 0 sampai p r minus1
semuanya bilangan real positif x0 sampai XR minus satu adalah vektor eigen ortonormal dari row dan R kebetulan merupakan
rank dari row dan omong-omong sebagai catatan sampingan perhatikan betapa seringnya kita menggunakan teorema spektral pada titik ini
itu adalah alat yang sangat berguna dan sebenarnya kita akan kebingungan tanpanya bagaimanapun sekarang setelah kita punya dekomposisi spektral
row kita bisa menghitung dekomposisi Schmid dari dua vektor kita seperti sebelumnya dan mereka akan
hampir persis sama koefisien dan vektor X-nya sama karena berasal dari dekomposisi spektral dari keadaan tereduksi yang
sama untuk kedua vektor satu-satunya perbedaan adalah kita mungkin mendapatkan vektor yang berbeda untuk sistem kedua untuk
vektor pertama yaitu s kita akan mendapatkan satu himpunan vektor y0 sampai y Rus satu dan untuk vektor kedua yaitu f kita akan
mendapatkan koleksi yang mungkin berbeda yang bisa kita sebut z0 sampai zrus satu jadi sekarang kita punya dekomposisi Schmid
untuk dua vektor kita yang terlihat sangat mirip kecuali vektor-vektor untuk sistem kedua mungkin berbeda tapi ini
adalah dekomposisi Schmid sehingga kedua koleksi ini keduanya bersifat ortonormal dan kita bisa dengan mudah memilih
matriks uniter U yang mengirim ya ke Za untuk setiap a kamu selalu bisa melakukan itu operasi
uniter sebenarnya setara dengan peta linear yang mengubah satu basis ortonormal menjadi yang lain dan jika
kedua himpunan ini kebetulan tidak mencakup seluruh ruang yang bersesuaian dengan Y kita selalu bisa memperluasnya menjadi basis
ortonormal menggunakan prosedur ortogonalisasi Gr-Schmid kebetulan dan itulah bagaimana
ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi dibuktikan dalam pelajaran keempat dari seri ini kita membahas protokol superdense coding
yang memungkinkan pengirim mengirimkan dua bit klasik ke penerima dengan mengirimkan satu qubit dengan biaya satu ebit dari
entanglement bersama jadi saya mengasumsikan bahwa kamu sudah familiar dengan protokol tersebut dan maksud dari contoh ini adalah untuk secara singkat
menjelaskan bagaimana itu terhubung dengan ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi ingat bahwa cara
protokol bekerja adalah Alice dan Bob berbagi sebuah ebit atau dengan kata lain keadaan Bell fi plus Alice memilih untuk mengubah
keadaan Bell tersebut menjadi salah satu dari Empat Keadaan Bell tergantung pada dua bit yang ingin dia kirim dan kemudian dia mengirimkan
Cubit-nya ke Bob dan dia mengukur untuk melihat keadaan Bell mana yang dia miliki perhatikan bahwa semua empat keadaan Bell
menghasilkan keadaan tereduksi yang sama untuk Cubit Bob yaitu keadaan campuran sepenuhnya dan sebenarnya itu sudah cukup
untuk menyimpulkan bahwa superdense coding itu mungkin semua empat keadaan Bell memurnikan keadaan campuran sepenuhnya sehingga dengan
ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi kita tahu bahwa pasti mungkin bagi Alice untuk mengubah keadaan Bell fi plus menjadi
yang lain dengan menerapkan beberapa operasi uniter pada Cubit-nya tentu saja tidak sulit untuk menemukan operasi uniter yang
benar-benar berhasil dan sangat sederhana tapi tetap menarik bahwa kita bisa mencapai kesimpulan bahwa ini adalah
hal yang mungkin tanpa bahkan memikirkan operasi uniter itu sendiri dan terlebih lagi kita bisa menyimpulkan
bahwa generalisasi superdense coding ke sistem yang lebih besar adalah mungkin asalkan kita memiliki cara untuk menggeneralisasi keadaan Bell ke sistem yang lebih besar
sedemikian sehingga semuanya menghasilkan keadaan campuran sepenuhnya sebagai keadaan tereduksi Bob dan sebenarnya ada berbagai cara yang diketahui untuk melakukan
itu pengaturan berbeda di mana ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi memiliki implikasi adalah
kriptografi kuantum dan salah satu implikasi terpentingnya adalah bahwa itu mengesampingkan keberadaan protokol kuantum yang aman tanpa syarat untuk
primitif kriptografi yang dikenal sebagai bit commitment jadi apa itu bit commitment bit commitment adalah contoh
dari primitif kriptografi yang dimaksudkan adalah tugas atau prosedur tingkat rendah yang menyediakan beberapa fungsi dasar yang
kemudian bisa digunakan sebagai blok bangunan untuk melakukan hal yang lebih menarik seperti membuat skema tanda tangan digital atau membangun
protokol zero knowledge misalnya dalam kasus bit commitment fungsi dasarnya adalah bahwa satu
pemain Alice bisa berkomitmen pada nilai biner pilihannya kepada pemain kedua Bob tapi pilihannya tetap tersembunyi
sampai dia memilih untuk mengungkapkannya kita memerlukan dua properti spesifik dari protokol yang mengimplementasikan bit
commitment itu harus bersifat binding yang berarti Alice tidak bisa mengubah pikirannya setelah berkomitmen pada suatu bit dan itu
harus bersifat concealing yang berarti Bob tidak bisa menentukan bit Alice sampai dia memilih untuk mengungkapkannya
jadi akan sangat bagus untuk bisa mengimplementasikan primitif ini menggunakan informasi kuantum karena ini adalah
primitif yang berguna tapi tanpa asumsi tambahan ternyata tidak mungkin untuk melakukannya dengan sempurna menggunakan informasi kuantum bahkan hampir sempurna pun tidak
dan ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi mengungkapkan ide ini pada level yang sangat tinggi
yaitu jika ada protokol kuantum untuk bit commitment maka harus ada versi yang dipurifikasi dari protokol tersebut di mana kita bisa bayangkan bahwa
Alice punya sistem a Bob punya sistem B dan setelah komitmen dibuat tapi sebelum Alice mengungkapkan pasangan AB berada dalam
salah satu dari dua keadaan murni ukuran nol atau I satu tergantung pada bit yang Alice
komitkan jika protokol ini sempurna concealing maka Bob tidak bisa membedakan antara kedua
komitmen sehingga keadaan tereduksinya harus sama untuk kedua kemungkinan namun itu mengimplikasikan berdasarkan
ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi bahwa Alice bisa mengubah salah satunya menjadi yang lain dengan menerapkan beberapa operasi uniter
pada a saja sehingga protokol ini sama sekali gagal bersifat binding ada detail-detail yang saya lewatkan tapi inti
permasalahannya adalah bahwa ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi memberi tahu kita bahwa primitif ini bukan sesuatu
yang bisa kita implementasikan dengan andal menggunakan informasi kuantum tanpa asumsi tambahan dari suatu
jenis contoh terakhir dari implikasi ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi adalah teorema yang dikenal sebagai
teorema Houston Joseph Wooters atau teorema hjw singkatnya mari kita mulai dengan pernyataan
teoremnya sendiri dan ini adalah versi yang sedikit disederhanakan hanya untuk menghindari beberapa kerumitan teknis agar kita bisa fokus pada ide-ide utama
misalkan X dan Y adalah sistem dan F adalah Vektor Keadaan Kuantum mana pun yang mewakili keadaan murni dari pasangan
XY dan sekarang misalkan kita memikirkan keadaan tereduksi dari sistem X saja dan kita menemukan cara apa pun yang kita
pilih untuk mengekspresikan keadaan tereduksi ini sebagai kombinasi cembung dari keadaan murni seperti yang ditampilkan di layar
jadi misalnya angka kapital N dalam ekspresi ini yang merupakan jumlah keadaan murni yang kita rata-ratakan bisa
sangat besar mungkin jauh lebih besar dari dimensi ruang yang bersesuaian dengan X atau Y untuk itu
dan apa yang dikatakan teorema adalah bahwa pasti ada pengukuran pada sistem y yang memiliki n hasil sedemikian sehingga
berikut terjadi saat sistem Y diukur pertama setiap hasil pengukuran
muncul dengan probabilitas yang tepat sama dengan probabilitas yang bersesuaian dalam ekspresi kita dari keadaan tereduksi X sebagai
kombinasi cembung dari keadaan murni dan kedua dikhususkan pada mendapatkan hasil pengukuran tertentu
keadaan X menjadi keadaan murni yang bersesuaian dari kombinasi cembung jadi kenapa itu
menarik nah artinya untuk cara apa pun yang kita pilih untuk memikirkan keadaan tereduksi X sebagai kombinasi cembung
dari keadaan murni ada beberapa pengukuran Y yang secara efektif membuat cara berpikir tentang keadaan tereduksi x ini menjadi
kenyataan dan yang luar biasa adalah bahwa ini mungkin bahkan ketika keadaan f dipilih pertama dan kombinasi cembung
dipilih kemudian selama itu adalah ekspresi dari keadaan tereduksi X akan ada
pengukuran Y yang bekerja persis seperti ini jadi mari kita lihat bagaimana kita bisa membuktikan
ini kita mulai dengan dua ekspresi berbeda untuk keadaan tereduksi X yang akan kita namai Row demi
kenyamanan selanjutnya kita memperkenalkan sistem baru Z yang keadaan klasiknya adalah kemungkinan hasil pengukuran atau
ekuivalennya indeks dalam kombinasi cembung kita dan sekarang kita bisa mengamati bahwa dua Vektor Keadaan Kuantum berikut
gamma 0 dan Gamma 1 yang keduanya merupakan vektor keadaan untuk sistem gabungan XYZ adalah
purifikasi dari row dan hanya untuk kejelasan saat kita memikirkan vektor-vektor ini sebagai purifikasi dari row kita
memikirkan sistem Y dan Z bersama-sama sebagai satu sistem gabungan yang di-trace out untuk meninggalkan
Row vektor pertama gamma 0er pada dasarnya sama dengan keadaan murni asal 5 kecuali bahwa kita
menginisialisasi sistem baru Z ke keadaan nol jelas bahwa jika kita me-Trace out Y dan Z kita akan mendapatkan row sehingga gamma
0er adalah purifikasi dari row vektor kedua Gamma 1 pada dasarnya adalah vektor yang kita dapatkan dengan memurnikan
row berdasarkan kombinasi cembung seperti yang saya jelaskan sebelumnya dalam pelajaran kali ini sistem Y
diinisialisasi dan saya mengasumsikan hanya demi kesederhanaan bahwa nol adalah keadaan klasik dari Y tapi kamu bisa mengganti keadaan basis standar mana pun
atau bahkan keadaan murni mana pun dari Y ke dalam ekspresi ini dan tidak akan membuat perbedaan dalam hal apapun me-trace out Y dan
Z kembali meninggalkan kita dengan row jadi intinya adalah keduanya adalah purifikasi dari row dan oleh karena itu berdasarkan
ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi ada operasi uniter U pada pasangan YZ yang mengubah gamma 0 menjadi
Gamma 1 dan itu saja yang kita butuhkan untuk memberikan deskripsi pengukuran yang melakukan apa yang dikatakan teorema
cara sederhana untuk menggambarkannya adalah dengan diagram circuit seperti yang ditampilkan di sini di layar dalam kata-kata kita mulai dengan
keadaan F kita memperkenalkan Z yang diinisialisasi ke keadaan nol lakukan U dan kemudian ukur sistem teratas yaitu Z dengan
pengukuran basis standar secara efektif apa yang ini lakukan adalah mengubah fi menjadi Gamma Satu dan
hanya dengan melihat deskripsi Gamma 1 kita bisa melihat bahwa ini melakukan apa yang dikatakan teorema yaitu kita mendapatkan
setiap hasil a dengan probabilitas PA dan dikhususkan pada mendapatkan a sistem X dibiarkan dalam keadaan sa
a dan hanya untuk kejelasan pengukuran itu sendiri yang implikasikan keberadaannya oleh teorema diimplementasikan oleh
semua yang ada di dalam persegi panjang putus-putus dalam gambar dan jika kamu ingin tahu bagaimana
pengukuran bisa dideskripsikan sebagai koleksi matriks berikut adalah ekspresinya saya tidak akan menjelaskan bagian ini dan itu
sebenarnya tidak terlalu penting demi contoh tapi itulah ekspresi matriks pengukuran jika kamu
tertarik selanjutnya kita akan membahas Fidelitas yang merupakan ukuran seberapa mirip dua keadaan kuantum atau alternatifnya seberapa
banyak mereka tumpang tindih kita akan mulai dengan definisi yang mungkin terlihat sedikit misterius pada
pandangan pertama tapi kita akan mengurainya dan pada akhir diskusi saya harap saya akan berhasil meyakinkan kamu bahwa itu adalah
sebenarnya fungsi yang jauh lebih bagus dari yang mungkin terlihat pada pandangan pertama dan inilah
definisinya Fidelitas antara dua matriks densitas row dan sigma sama dengan trace dari akar kuadrat dari
akar kuadrat row dikali Sigma dikali akar kuadrat row kita akan membahasnya
pertama-tama mari kita coba memahami definisi itu sendiri kita punya tiga akar kuadrat dan
semuanya mengacu pada akar kuadrat dari matriks semi-definit positif yang seperti yang kita bahas dalam pelajaran sebelumnya adalah
matriks semi-definit positif unik yang dikuadratkan untuk menghasilkan matriks apa pun yang kita ambil akarnya karena
row adalah matriks densitas itu harus semi-definit positif sehingga kita bisa mengambil akarnya dan jika kita memikirkan akar row kali
Sigma akar row sejenak kita melihat bahwa itu juga semi-definit positif dan khususnya kita bisa menulisnya sebagai
M dagger kali M untuk M adalah akar kuadrat dari Sigma dikali akar kuadrat dari row dan oleh karena itu kita bisa mengambil akar
kudratnya khususnya kita bisa menghitung dekomposisi spektral dari akar
row kali Sigma dikali akar row dan kemudian untuk mengambil akar kuadrat kita hanya perlu mengambil akar kuadrat dari nilai
eigen dan membiarkan vektor eigen tetap sama dan akhirnya kita mengambil trace dari
matriks ini dan karena trace sama dengan jumlah nilai eigen kita mendapatkan ekspresi yang kita miliki di
sini jadi itu mungkin sesuatu yang tidak ingin kamu hitung secara manual pada umumnya dan penjelasan ini mungkin tidak
memberikan banyak wawasan tentang Fidelitas atau mengapa kita peduli dengannya tapi semoga ini memperjelas makna teknis
dari rumusan omong-omong sebagai catatan sampingan kadang orang mendefinisikan Fidelitas
sebagai kuadrat dari fungsi yang telah saya definisikan di sini dan mereka menyebut fungsi ini sebagai root
Fidelitas kamu akan melihatnya didefinisikan dengan kedua cara yang tentu saja berpotensi menyebabkan kebingungan tapi biasanya tidak
karena orang umumnya cukup berhati-hati dalam menjelaskan definisi mana yang mereka gunakan dan kamu harus
pastikan untuk melakukan hal yang sama menurut saya sebenarnya tidak ada definisi yang benar atau salah saya mendefinisikannya
seperti ini semata-mata karena saya terbiasa melakukannya dengan cara ini dan saya merasa itu sedikit lebih nyaman mungkin karena saya lebih suka mengkuadratkan
sesuatu daripada mengambil akar kuadrat kemudian saat diperlukan tapi tentu saja kamu bebas membuat pilihanmu
sendiri bagaimanapun mari saya kembali ke Fidelitas seperti yang didefinisikan di sini ada cara-cara setara lain untuk
mendefinisikan Fidelitas dan ini sebenarnya adalah fungsi yang cukup luar biasa dalam hal itu dan bisa dikategorikan dengan cara yang cukup menarik
berikut adalah cara yang cukup langsung untuk menulis ulang definisi dalam bentuk trace Norm yang kita lihat menjelang
akhir pelajaran sebelumnya saya tidak terlalu detail tentang trace norm dan khususnya saya
bahkan tidak mendefinisikannya untuk matriks non-Hermitian tapi memang ada definisi yang cukup sederhana satu cara untuk mendefinisikan trace Norm dari
matriks sembarang m adalah trace dari akar kuadrat M kali M dagger atau ekuivalennya trace dari akar
kuadrat M dagger kali M kamu mendapatkan nilai yang sama dari mana pun kamu melakukannya dan kita bisa menggunakan definisi tersebut untuk menyederhanakan
definisi Fidelitas seperti yang kita miliki di bawah sini di bagian bawah layar dan itu bagus karena mengungkapkan bahwa
itu simetris dalam dua argumen kita juga bisa mengekspresikan trace Norm dari matriks persegi M sebagai
maksimum dari nilai absolut dari trace M kali U yang mencakup semua matriks uniter U yang tidak jelas tapi itu
benar dan itu memberi kita ekspresi lain untuk Fidelitas jadi di sini kita punya tiga
definisi yang setara untuk Fidelitas dan itu baru permulaan ada beberapa definisi setara lainnya dan
kita akan melihat satu yang sangat penting yang berasal dari teorema Uhlmann menjelang akhir pelajaran
oke jadi itu bagus tapi apa artinya semua itu pada level intuitif dan mengapa kita harus peduli dengan
fungsi ini untuk menjawab pertanyaan-pertanyaan ini akan sangat membantu mempertimbangkan kasus khusus di mana setidaknya salah satu dari dua matriks densitas
mewakili keadaan murni jika kedua keadaan murni maka
Fidelitas hanyalah nilai absolut dari hasil kali dalam antara dua Vektor Keadaan Kuantum dan dalam beberapa hal
ini adalah motivasi utama untuk Fidelitas itu sendiri nilai absolut dari hasil kali dalam antara dua Vektor Keadaan Kuantum
selalu merupakan angka antara nol dan satu dan memberikan cara alami untuk mengukur seberapa banyak tumpang tindih yang ada
antara dua Vektor Keadaan Kuantum dan kamu bisa memikirkan Fidelitas sebagai cara yang berguna dan berperilaku baik untuk
memperluas cara mengukur tumpang tindih ini dari keadaan murni ke matriks densitas jika salah satu keadaan murni
dan yang lainnya belum tentu murni maka kita kembali punya ekspresi sederhana untuk Fidelitas yang bisa cukup
berguna dan ekspresi itu ditampilkan di sini Fidelitas memiliki banyak properti menarik
dan itu adalah salah satu alasan mengapa orang menggunakannya ia memiliki definisi yang tidak benar-benar
terlalu bagus tapi ia adalah fungsi yang sangat berguna meski begitu dan sering sangat mudah digunakan sebagian karena banyaknya
properti luar biasanya jadi mari kita lihat beberapa di antaranya dimulai dengan pengamatan bahwa Fidelitas antara dua matriks densitas
selalu merupakan angka antara 0 dan satu ia nol jika dan hanya jika keadaan-keadaan
bersifat ortogonal yang artinya gambar-gambarnya adalah subruang ortogonal atau ekuivalennya bahwa hasil kali dua matriks adalah
nol dan Fidelitas adalah satu jika dan hanya jika dua matriks densitas tersebut sama setiap kasus lain ada di suatu tempat di
antara tapi secara intuitif semakin dekat Fidelitas ke satu semakin mirip keadaan-keadaan tersebut atau alternatifnya
semakin banyak mereka tumpang tindih Fidelitas juga simetris saya menyebutkan itu beberapa saat yang lalu ini
cukup jelas dari ekspresi yang kita lihat untuk Fidelitas dalam bentuk trace Norm tapi ini adalah hal penting untuk diakui
selanjutnya Fidelitas bersifat multiplikatif untuk keadaan produk yang berarti Fidelitas antara dua
keadaan produk selalu sama dengan hasil kali fidelitas antara masing-masing
keadaan berikut adalah properti yang sangat berguna jika kita punya dua matriks densitas berukuran sama
beserta channel mana pun yang mengambil matriks densitas ini sebagai input Fidelitas hanya bisa menjadi lebih besar saat channel tersebut
diterapkan pada kedua keadaan jadi dengan kata lain dalam hal Fidelitas channel hanya bisa membuat keadaan
lebih mirip satu sama lain mereka tidak bisa membuatnya kurang mirip dan akhirnya untuk daftar ini paling tidak
ada hubungan yang cukup erat antara Fidelitas dan jarak trace antara keadaan yang didefinisikan
sebagai setengah trace Norm dari selisih antara dua matriks densitas jarak trace antara dua
keadaan sangat berhubungan dengan seberapa baik kita bisa membedakannya yang kita bahas dalam pelajaran sebelumnya dalam konteks
diskriminasi keadaan dan teorema Helstrom-Holevo sementara Fidelitas mengukur seberapa banyak dua keadaan
tumpang tindih jadi meskipun keduanya tidak persis sama tidaklah mengejutkan bahwa ada hubungan antara kedua
besaran ini tapi bagaimanapun ketidaksamaan-ketidaksamaan ini yang biasanya disebut ketidaksamaan Fuchs-van de Graaf
membuat hubungan ini tepat secara matematis dan sangat penting bahwa tidak ada sama sekali ketergantungan di sini pada ukuran sistem yang kita bicarakan
kita bisa melihat hubungan ini sedikit lebih jelas dengan bantuan sebuah gambar jika kita punya dua keadaan dan kita
menempatkan jarak trace antara keduanya di sumbu x dan Fidelitas di sumbu y maka garis vertikal dan
horizontal yang bersesuaian harus berpotongan di suatu tempat di dalam wilayah abu-abu ini wilayah yang paling menarik dari
plotnya omong-omong setidaknya secara praktis adalah sudut kiri atas dari wilayah abu-abu khususnya ketika
jarak trace sangat kecil Fidelitas harus sangat dekat dengan satu dan sebaliknya
ketidaksamaan-ketidaksamaan ini sangat sering digunakan dan sebagian alasannya adalah bahwa kita seringkali lebih peduli dengan
jarak trace pada akhirnya karena memiliki interpretasi alami yang terhubung dengan diskriminasi Keadaan Kuantum
tapi Fidelitas memiliki begitu banyak properti luar biasa sehingga umumnya lebih mudah untuk digunakan dan selama kita berada di sudut kiri atas dari
wilayah abu-abu yang sering kita temui kita tidak kehilangan terlalu banyak dengan berpindah antara Fidelitas dan jarak trace jadi itu
adalah beberapa properti dari Fidelitas masih banyak lagi tapi ini adalah awal yang baik dan semoga daftarnya
membantu mulai mengembangkan intuisi tentang Fidelitas berikut adalah contoh bagus tentang bagaimana kita
bisa menghubungkan Fidelitas dengan pengukuran non-destruktif ini adalah fakta yang sangat berguna yang dikenal sebagai Lemma pengukuran
gentle misalkan kita punya sistem x sebuah keadaan dari X yang diwakili oleh matriks densitas row dan sebuah pengukuran pada sistem X
yang dijelaskan oleh koleksi matriks semi-definit positif misalkan salah satu hasil pengukuran sangat mungkin untuk
muncul jika kita melakukan pengukuran pada keadaan row hanya demi kesederhanaan misalkan
itu adalah hasil Z Z yang sangat mungkin dan khususnya misalkan kita mengasumsikan bahwa hasil ini muncul dengan
probabilitas lebih besar dari 1 minus Epsilon untuk beberapa nilai Epsilon yang kecil yang tidak benar-benar perlu kita tentukan Epsilon
adalah sekadar bilangan real positif kecil sekarang kita telah mendeskripsikan pengukuran kita seolah-olah itu adalah pengukuran
destruktif tapi kita tahu dari pelajaran sebelumnya bahwa kita bisa mengimplementasikan pengukuran ini dengan cara non-destruktif dan secara khusus kita bisa melakukannya sebagai
yang kita lihat dalam diskusi kita tentang teorema Naymark dan cara kerjanya adalah setiap hasil a muncul dengan
probabilitas sama dengan trace dari PA kali row dan dikhususkan pada mendapatkan hasil itu keadaan X berubah dalam
khususnya dalam kasus kita mendapatkan hasil yang mungkin yaitu nol keadaan menjadi akar kuadrat dari p 0 kali row dikali akar kuadrat dari p 0
semuanya dinormalisasi sehingga kita mendapatkan matriks densitas dan apa yang dikatakan lemma pengukuran gentle kepada kita adalah bahwa dalam kejadian ini
yang berarti kita memang mendapatkan hasil pengukuran yang mungkin keadaan yang kita dapatkan tidak akan banyak berubah dari
keadaan asal dan khususnya Fidelitas kuadrat akan harus lebih besar dari 1 minus
Epsilon dan ini bagus karena ini sangat umum kita tidak mengatakan apa pun tentang pengukuran atau
keadaan kecuali bahwa salah satu hasilnya sangat mungkin jadi Lemma bisa diterapkan dalam
banyak pengaturan berbeda di mana kita ingin memverifikasi sesuatu tentang Keadaan Kuantum tanpa banyak mengganggunya jadi mari kita lihat bagaimana kita bisa membuktikan
ini dan sebagian besar sebenarnya ini adalah masalah yang cukup sederhana untuk menghitung Fidelitas antara keadaan sebelum dan sesudah pengukuran
kita bisa melakukan ini dengan menggunakan definisi asli dan biasanya itu bisa meninggalkan kita dengan rumus yang rumit tapi
dalam kasus ini kita beruntung karena sesuatu di dalam akar kuadrat terluar sebenarnya adalah kuadrat dari matriks yang
kebetulan semi-definit positif yang membuat pengitungan akar kuadrat menjadi sepele kita sekarang bisa menggunakan properti siklik
dari trace beserta linieritas trace untuk menyederhanakan ekspresi kita seperti yang ditampilkan di layar perhatikan omong-omong bahwa ini semua adalah
persamaan sehingga kita belum mengaproksimasi apa pun pada titik ini kita benar-benar hanya menyederhanakan tapi sekarang kita memerlukan sebuah
ketidaksamaan karena kita ingin menghilangkan akar kuadrat di pembilang dan kita memang bisa melakukan itu jika kita bersedia puas dengan batas bawah dan jika
kamu tertarik dengan detailnya untuk bagian ini kamu bisa mendapatkan ketidaksamaan tersebut dengan cukup mudah dengan mempertimbangkan dekomposisi spektral dari p
0 nilai eigen dari p 0 harus antara 0 dan satu itu selalu benar untuk matriks yang mendeskripsikan
pengukuran dan begitu kita tahu itu ketidaksamaan tersebut mengikuti cukup langsung dari fakta bahwa mengambil akar kuadrat dari
bilangan antara 0 dan satu hanya bisa membuatnya lebih besar cara lain untuk menyatakannya adalah mengkuadratkan bilangan antara nol dan
satu hanya bisa membuatnya lebih kecil kita sekarang bisa menyederhanakan sedikit lagi dan kita mendapatkan akar
kuadrat dari trace dari p 0 kali row akhirnya mengkuadratkan kedua sisi dan
memasukkan batas kita pada probabilitas memberi kita apa yang kita inginkan jadi rumusnya untuk Fidelitas
bukanlah rumus yang paling bagus atau paling mudah digunakan di dunia tapi di sini ia bekerja dengan cukup
bagus untuk mengakhiri pelajaran kita akan melihat teorema Uhlmann yang merupakan fakta fundamental tentang Fidelitas yang
menghubungkannya dengan konsep purifikasi apa yang dikatakan teorema dalam istilah sederhana adalah bahwa Fidelitas antara dua
Keadaan Kuantum mana pun sama dengan hasil kali dalam maksimum dalam nilai absolut antara dua purifikasi dari keadaan-keadaan
tersebut dengan lebih rinci misalkan row dan sigma adalah matriks densitas untuk beberapa sistem X dan misalkan Y adalah
sistem yang memiliki setidaknya sebanyak Keadaan Klasik seperti X dan oleh karena itu kita dijamin bahwa kedua keadaan ini punya purifikasi yang merupakan
vektor keadaan kuantum dari XY kita kemudian bisa mengekspresikan implikasi dari teorema dalam bentuk persamaan
yang ditampilkan di layar Fidelitas antara row dan sigma sama dengan nilai absolut maksimum dari hasil kali dalam
antara F dan SII yang mencakup semua fi dan S yang memurnikan row dan sigma
masing-masing jadi mari kita bersihkan ini dan bekerja dengan pernyataan matematis yang tepat ke depannya apa yang akan kita lakukan sekarang adalah membuktikan
teoremanya tapi pertama-tama ada baiknya meluangkan waktu untuk menghargai bahwa ia menawarkan cara yang cukup intuitif untuk memikirkan
Fidelitas ia juga ternyata cukup berguna tersendiri misalnya untuk membuktikan hal-hal yang bahkan lebih menarik tentang
Fidelitas untuk membuktikannya kita akan mulai dengan dekomposisi spektral dari matriks densitas kita
tidak ada kejutan di sana begitu kita punya dekomposisi spektral mudah untuk menemukan
dua purifikasi spesifik dari keadaan-keadaan ini tapi di sini kita sebenarnya akan melakukan sebuah
trik perhatikan bahwa dalam kedua kasus kita tidak punya basis standar VOR sebagai faktor tensor kedua seperti yang kita lakukan sebelumnya dalam
pelajaran tapi justru kita punya vektor yang sama seperti di faktor tensor pertama kecuali bahwa ia memiliki tanda bar di atasnya dan
itu berarti konjugat kompleks entry-wise dari vektor-vektor ini jadi dengan kata lain kita pada dasarnya hanya mengambil
salinan kedua dari vektor eigen tapi kita mengambil konjugat kompleks dari setiap entri dan kita akan melihat mengapa kita melakukan itu dalam beberapa
saat tapi sama sekali tidak jelas bahwa kita harus melakukan ini dan itulah mengapa kita menyebutnya sebuah
trik bagaimanapun ini adalah purifikasi dari row dan sigma masing-masing dan itu benar berdasarkan
fakta bahwa vektor eigen kita bersifat ortonormal dan oleh karena itu begitu juga konjugat kompleks entry-wise mereka dan sekarang kita bisa menerapkan
ekuivalensi uniter dari purifikasi yang mengatakan bahwa setiap purifikasi dari dua keadaan kita bisa diperoleh dengan
menerapkan operasi uniter pada sistem yang di-trace out untuk pilihan purifikasi spesifik yang
baru saja kita buat operasi uniter tidak harus sama untuk kedua purifikasi
tentu saja jadi di sini kita menggunakan huruf U untuk yang pertama dan huruf V untuk yang
kedua jadi intinya adalah bahwa setiap purifikasi dari dua keadaan kita bisa ditulis seperti yang kita miliki di layar untuk
beberapa pilihan operasi uniter u dan v dan sekarang kita bisa mengambil ekspresi
dari teorema dan menyederhanakannya jika kita memasukkan ekspresi kita untuk F dan S dan menyederhanakan sedikit kita
mendapatkan ekspresi yang ditampilkan di sini di layar sekarang ada beberapa langkah di sana dan saya belum menunjukkan detailnya
jadi kamu tahu apa yang harus dilakukan jika kamu mau tapi izinkan saya menyebutkan bahwa alasan mengapa kita memilih purifikasi seperti yang kita lakukan
adalah untuk memungkinkan hasil kali dalam ini disederhanakan persis dengan cara ini dan khususnya kita meletakkan konjugat kompleks
di sana agar kita bisa secara efektif membalikkan hasil kali dalam di faktor tensor kedua untuk mendapatkan bentuk
spesifik yang kita miliki di sini kita hampir sampai sekarang kita bisa menggunakan properti siklik dari trace beserta
dekomposisi spektral yang kita mulai untuk mendapatkan ekspresi ini dan pada titik ini kita bisa
menggunakan salah satu cara alternatif mengekspresikan Fidelitas menggunakan trace norm dan kita
selesai tentu saja ada detail yang saya lewatkan sangat cepat dan ini adalah jenis bukti yang benar-benar perlu kamu kerjakan
sendiri untuk sepenuhnya memahaminya tapi semoga ini memberikan ide dasarnya
dan seperti biasa kamu bisa menemukan lebih banyak detail dalam konten tertulis untuk pelajaran ini yang ditautkan dalam deskripsi video
dan itulah akhir dari pelajaran ini yang membahas tentang purifikasi Fidelitas dan hubungan antara keduanya dan ini juga merupakan
akhir dari unit yang membahas tentang formulasi umum dari informasi kuantum saya harap kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk
unit keempat dan terakhir dari seri ini yang membahas tentang koreksi error kuantum terima kasih telah menonton